so suppose that movie I want to get my
clown you so bad by but probably friend
remember what am i sorry I remember what
I did I did I was in China and I was New
Orleans doing that movie yes by the way
my psoriasis was like I was just covered
in psoriasis it was so hot I was so
miserable but it's my dear friend Gil
and he did a children's movie it's a
kids movie about a talking dog with
Megan Fox and Josh from a good movie for
kids a great family movie
so he goes will you post my trailer I go
of course you're my boy I'll do it I
didn't realize that wasn't in the
trailer so I made all yeah our fans
watch a [ __ ] horror movie that I'm
gonna so bad that they're all [ __ ]
older it was so bad that wasn't in it I
thought Brian's older I've got roads
that people were like you know I've
never read comments I read every comment
was so funny that Chris goes dodging guy
yeah you play the steaming pile of dog
[ __ ] this I mean they they were
there were so many funny [ __ ] texts
they were just like so funny hey Joker
Christos you played the first Asian guy
this guy goes is this another I'm in the
Joker movie thing yeah guys sorry I made
you watch that I had no idea now watch
this by the way this might have hurt my
friends movie cuz everybody's like get
out of here
here here I am saying this one is sorry
yeah hey guys I guess I posted that I
mean you guys watch that hey Chrissy us
I want to be positive resent Chris goes
I want it to be clear you post that
didn't make one and I mean one person
wants to go see that movie I wish you
and the person who asked you to post
that understand how the goddamn
I got solos then it got so bad that my
friends were calling on dude geez you
got to take this down like I'm never
taking it down I deserve it I should
look at what I'm posting before I post
it I'm just like he's my friend of
course I'll do it you do favors for us I
did I actually hurt his movie I will
never see that move in I don't want to
hate the movie already to Chris's point
the guy who asked you to post the
trailer and you post it no one's gonna
see it yeah yeah because it's so
frustrating that sucks Brian you ruined
a whole movie oh come on please
Joe honey they put into that and it is
it animated its Lionsgate no no what is
it it's not having seen the trailer oh
that's awful so much money put into that
and you [ __ ] Rock come on yeah one
day earlier you played that first like a
dog so you're an awful person no come on
the movie dude that's your friend's name
Gill younger oh he hates you I apologize
Gill he directed 10 Things I Hate About
You
oh he now it's 11 11 things 11 so you
think you've shat on me this whole
podcast
yo hungover right now and ask me why I
know is your tummy hurt you drink wine
left no pizza I ate some pie I had a lot
of pancakes this morning thought they
said adderall I thought you guys no no I
just I know I mentioned I may like kids
pancakes and then there was leftover and
I had a shitload of it so you made a ton
of packets if you had a shitload of hate
idol I made it I'm Anton pancakes I just
said I'm gonna eat a stack of pancakes
bad right yeah well no no good tasty
very tasty
yeah live a little dude I mean come on
well this wrong with a [ __ ] with
pancakes so you don't feel good he said
I just feel funny
we see you've hung over so that'd be my
head feels like it's in my head feels
like it's in pillows does that weird do
you think it's the pancakes I doubt it
my head feels like I'm like somebody has
pillows around my ears and my head's hot
my head's very hot oh yes the pink I
think the pancakes make my oh it's not a
fever everybody I'm talking about I feel
like I feel like like whenever I do is I
feel like my eyes have pillows in them
my head my head
just feel like in wet cement when I eat
shitty food interesting yeah I think
it's an insulin rush you get syrup with
it I sure did
who the [ __ ] each dry pan Cajun are you
with butter sometimes God deals butter
yeah I [ __ ] love panko so on American
and I'll tell you something else I like
I like ice cream sandwiches from cool
house oh they're so [ __ ] a I even
like the [ __ ] coconut ones that that
cookie you put them between two [ __ ]
delicious cookies hmm right there okay
Haitian that Tahitian vanilla God aren't
they German I don't know but that did
the dairy-free ones are really good too
they're all father's sugar in them hell
yeah yeah see how much sugar is in one
of those goddamn sandwiches if they're
that tasty thank you dude they're so
good though I cut them up because you
don't want the big no I don't want the
whole you want D please then I'll die 23
grams 23 grams a lot of sugar is that a
lot death bless you that's a lot but not
a lot for a cookie ice cream sandwich I
would imagine hold on hold on hold up
hold up
it's 60 grams well I'm sorry it's 40
grams yeah see that's what I like it 46
grams of [ __ ] sugar and it's 530
calories and 330 are from fat mm-hmm
seems like 60 grams of carbs it seems
like quite a bit
thanks cream and if you're counting
calories explain ice cream [ __ ] off
right you need to get Kovac eat eat your
goddamn pancakes sometimes need an ice
cream sandwich sometimes it seems like
you're doing every night Bill Bubba no
no I've been good
my body hasn't so my body's tight you're
lying I feel strong you're lying Ryan
that beach cruiser and your deep
throwing ice cream saying I'm eating I'm
having some problems yeah it's just this
Cobra to do it today so we're like
hovering right above I wish I could be
able to squat like that there's no way I
could do that you can't hold it I can't
hold that I'm too big too I'm feeling
just too big no you just don't work on
your got to and you not do this I could
do that but I can't squat on a toilet no
I feel like I want to fall on my feet
and my foots gonna slip out or something
it's crazy
[Music]
what's this okay so uh Machine Gun Kelly
recently made a video that he posted
onto Instagram where he found out that
his next-door neighbor who is let me see
what his name is Jeff Lewis I think
that's his name his neighbor is B is a
host of a show and he also has a podcast
and he MGK found out about this podcast
listen to it and realized that his
neighbors hate him and he just made this
video um Colson across the street oh oh
yes now I have no issue with this guy
there's this whatever tension brewing
and he said it was actually gonna turn
into the movie neighbors and that he is
Zac Efron which means that I'm [ __ ]
Seth Rogen yesterday the way machine gun
Kelly's a dirty 30 birthday a lot about
him at 5:00 p.m. that's to them 5:30 is
day drinking a big cake in the shape of
it the tower right you can see your
house in the background
they split parking from the 500 they
parked from the fire iron about we're
talking other people's driveways it's
just like I think they're so [ __ ] up
yeah that they just just stopped the car
wherever it right where the man is hot
girl or guys just in front of the G with
the G Wagen that was blocking my
neighbor's driveway they have to
understand I don't hate them right my
neighbor's hate them because my
neighbors have complained about them to
me every time the cops show up or every
time a car gets towed or every time
somebody gets a ticket they're assuming
it's me it's not now I know okay Jeff as
the new guy on the block referring to
you I wish we would have had a chance to
meet
I'm sure there's years of noise to come
from my house so I hope that we just
have mutual understanding
and if you ever need anything just come
knocking until then I'm gonna send this
over your way
cheers neighbor right Colson across the
street is he big machine comes no no I'm
saying does he make a lot of money yeah
he's very popular and his neighbor got
it well that's cool so I'll be friends
that's cool okay no move your car
I said no please move your car that's
hilarious she's amazing no she got
thicker yeah yeah a lot thicker I think
I think we live in a time now where
people are realizing that thicker women
are hot I think they are always half
well thicker but not obese yeah yeah
yeah like people are giving Adele [ __ ]
for losing weight you know that people
are hating on of course you know who are
hating on her the fat girls not you how
can you do this to us
she used to be a representative because
she got healthy you've had cards yeah
cuz she stopped putting chocolate on her
vegetables yeah because she's not
drinking ranch [ __ ] yourself [ __ ]
yourself hope your heart stops yeah you
were getting mad at her it's like oh my
bad my bad
here's the thing man I don't care I
don't care she's big or small the voice
is ridiculous
well it's the same ring holders I think
that weight kind of she's amazing she's
uneasy I didn't understand why she was
so big right like when she blew up with
that song and then I saw her sing it and
I was like holy [ __ ] I spilled a case
and I've ever had was I went to Costa
Rica my buddy Dan and his two boys and
in my children now Costa Rica is home to
the fair to Lance and also [ __ ] and
panto [ __ ] Brendon cuz we had the
Hornet we've been there to care brother
as bats were party there we that's right
and there are we went into a bar
thinking it was a bar and I'm not a joke
it was a piranha bar I couldn't believe
I went I go there and I go look at these
what's all these girls doing and Brennan
goes
No and then I walk in and I'm like why
am I being treated like I'm Elvis
Presley dude I'm not that good-looking
and then we were like oh these are
hookers it was a sea of hookers but
unbelievable yeah I mean I was that
wasn't stri was I was appalled I was - I
was appalled I was I didn't take well
bring this up there you go that's the
kind of [ __ ] you have to deal with in
Costa Rica and I don't approve I don't
approve I think it's an outrage if
you're into girls from Colombia and
Panama and that part of the world who
are crazy curvy and just $25 go a long
way some would say the longest out there
so I'm would say the longest Brendan I
don't know first hand I've heard I've
heard
there you go hundred dollars you're
living like Elon Musk out there they
have a hundred bucks you're livin like
Elon they're trying to suck that test
Tesla to you well there's there's there
are and it's unbelievable stakes are are
plenty oh dude trouser snakes are just
but I'm there I'm this you would
appreciate it because his kids are at
the time he's got a four-year-old he's
got a six-year-old now these kids were
amateur insect ologist and snake ology
service of course problem was we got
poisonous frogs
we got fair - Lance's we got Boomslang
so it's wreaking us
oh dude we got some of the scariest
[ __ ] snakes around of course not Iike
right we got weirder Lance's way and we
got Hornets aplenty we got fire ants we
got killer Hornets up there dude these
kids were groping at anything they could
find the bushes and and the poison dart
frog was the dad thing well dad was
[ __ ] worried too on top of the fact
they found a 20-foot crocodile on the
goddamn [ __ ] beach because the river
head was just oh a quote unquote
200 meters down the way he founded the
kids it was on the beach in the morning
and they told so I go I got my kids in
this water not how you get the [ __ ] out
of here
I was so stressed I finally grabbed the
kids I go look at me oh and then they
have the they have the eyelash Viper or
whatever it's called us then the hanging
of the trees budget of morte yeah they
bite you in the face and I saw one we
saw one and I'm like dude this this
whole situation is very danger
hey hey I swear to God
yellow I last fight we saw I don't know
cuz I last we saw they're better than
water
that thing is [ __ ] terrified it's
also adorable
now what we did all the cute ones we did
and you know why all they look like How
to Train Your Dragon the guy had to I
would it out to me that one doesn't yeah
but the guy had to point it out too
because I didn't see it until I got
right up on it because that's unless
that
dude I my eyes are so trained cuz when
you're mountain biking especially on the
narrow trail which it's a single path
yeah and there's just you know twigs and
everything my eyes just glued to the
ground my headphones are out and I'm
just going I'm just waiting for any sort
of movement or thick and whenever if I'm
on the dirt trail it's really hot out I
know I know their ways I don't like to
come Sun Tan so if I see a like a stick
that looks like this I always go around
of course and I come back in a snake I
get off film it free hose trimming your
hair is just growing it off looks good
[ __ ] looks soft up top dude soft is
nice right its course
yeah it's a nice hair it's a good length
yeah I'm a good-looking guy I want to
thank the fans for coming out on loss
and saying that thank you so much
everybody
everyone loves the short hair they
really do I want to keep it for the gold
I mean for school weekend uh-huh
I don't know I'm gonna ask them it'd be
so much easier we because I wasn't gonna
wear I got to do all this stuff with my
hair and though I'll just keep it like
this oh yeah your gym coach yeah sure
like a much is there but I got a look
shitty with shaved without a beard yeah
I just look bad what's up you look sick
when you feel I look gross
I like a beard you might look younger
with the shaved head and shaved beard
but you might look like mr. clean yeah I
don't think you should definitely have
the facial hair so we have well you
can't for a Goldberg I know that sucks
Lucy let me see what happen I was in a
the Philippines right I just shown the
Philippines and then uh was guy the
Iranian general that got assassinated
the Jomon or whatever so they want
Soleimani Salman so that's all over the
news in the Philippines right and I'm
scheduled to play Dubai the next week
after that assassination and I'm telling
my manager I'm like I don't remember
they were making all the threats they're
enough you're gonna do some dudes gonna
shoot some missiles over to Dubai and my
managers like just go bad just go it
believe me Dubai it's good that's
like--that's managers were like what are
you taught are you not watching the news
we just killed the Iranian junk do you
don't Dubai is it's next door right
but you were fine we were no rabbi nuts
tip I was beautiful how many people is
it I played a coca-cola arena can you
not look at the cameras as Mike here can
you not look like you yes but I don't
notarize that wine is that a lot of
people you can't was that a lot of
people huh is that low there look look
that's beautiful
can I say this though I'm walk-in down
the street we're doing like a commercial
right for a Dubai and two military
Black Hawks fly down the middle Black
Hawks is it called Black Hawks a
conscious black top black black hawk
yeah you really yeah which one's Mike
Cox or black Joe which was my hashtag
black know what do I have to black black
okay because it's got to go far too now
not Black Hawk dude cuz I got a lot of
likes when I said black hashtag black
top coca-cola Reena
yeah that's coca-cola Reena so ah so
check this out I
we're doing the advertisement right oh
I'm doing like it's like come to Dubai
you know is one of those things and
these two [ __ ] black black doc talks
with propellers on them yeah come right
down the middle man like low they're low
fly and they fly right over us we had to
stop it's just like you know
so loud bro all of our hearts were
stopped because they're gonna drop some
bro it just happened we just killed the
guy three four days ago and here's my
manager Blake I know we're in Bonner we
gonna be good and these two Black Hawks
come right down man it was the scariest
[ __ ] and were they Apache it was bigger
than the other than that no war how come
you saw everything man you saw the
missiles give that to you as it's a gift